[Music]
the title of Grandmaster was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Invitational that
tradition continues eight of the nine
rounds have been completed here in st.
Louis and at this GM and I am norma vent
we know at least one person isn't going
home empty-handed 12-year old Justin
Wang clinched his sixth point in this
tournament and his first I am norm
against any weighing he had the white
pieces at the start of the round
Justin was all nerves he was up and
walking around constantly looking at his
opponent's moves on the digital board
outside and would come back make his
move and then hurry on back out to the
rest of the tournament hall there is a
fifteen thousand dollar prize fund the
higher you score the more money you make
the final round is on Wednesday November
22 at 11:00 a.m. a playoff if necessary
will be at 4:00 p.m.
I'm here with international master John
Michael Burke in the Grand Master norm
section today his game was a draw but it
was the game of the day going in we knew
against Daniel Gurevich both players
four and a half points now you have five
and the norm is still attainable for
both of you we already talked to Daniel
what were your thoughts coming into this
game today well today I definitely
wanted to win because tomorrow I have
black and there's a lot tougher when we
black
he he had an idea here where I could
play kind of greedily and try and hold
on to the pawn but I think he can play
riff d8 and I don't really know what to
do here because if I play Rick f2 then
he can take because of the back rank so
I thought I would temporarily give the
pawn back but I'll always win one of
them back and I was considering taking
immediately
but I didn't like the line here he goes
Rick f1 and now up a pond but I'm kind
of tied down and he can try to harass me
by threatening to play this should be
three and I couldn't really find
anything for example if I play rook c3
he can go back and if d3 he can now play
Bishop a3 and now he's threatening to
come around to c5 and I couldn't really
believe that I could be tied down like
this and be better so I played rugby 1
and he took that opportunity to activate
his rook rook e2 and now he he handed me
a few Tempe for free he could have just
brought his King in immediately but he
he started by going the wrong way and
then he realized that I'm I'm just gonna
play rook F 1 and invade on the F file
so you had to bring his King back and
that was very helpful for me but I
really don't believe it's winning anyway
the one opportunity I might have had is
to trade rose but I thought he arrived
in time he brings this came to e4 and I
had a feeling that I couldn't really win
this one because if I play like King at
age 3 for example he can play King f3
and then Bishop f6 and my King can't
really get in and I couldn't really
believe that it would be winning maybe
it was a better try than what I did
because I didn't get anything going in
the game but yeah it was weird because
the whole game I thought it was better
but I couldn't really find any clear
improvement for me
around here I was even a bit optimistic
because it looks like I've got
everything covered and then I can maybe
play King 83 next and bring my king in
but I think that I have nothing because
King if I was a very good move if I play
like works III I can't take the pawn
because I'm pinned and I can't do it
here either because well I can do it in
fact it might have been the best drive
but we get a 2 vs. 1 and I don't really
believe I have anything close to winning
chances here I can cut his King off but
I really don't know what to do next
he can play like waiting moves for
example he could play here and if I try
and bring my King around he can play
rook after 3 and that would treat
everything to a dead drop but probably
that's what I had to try because the way
it went my dears to play King's g3 but
of course you can play this and now I
have nothing at all if I play row c3
here
then he can play here and again I can't
take the pun because he can go to d4 and
if this then I'm the one fighting for
the draw but what I did wasn't really
any better because I'm completely pinned
down he's threatening to to play Bishop
d4 anyway and if I play that King f1
trying to run away then he can annoy my
king with rook e1 if I go King you two
can go wreck b2 and if I play this
there was no way I'm completely tied
down I can't possibly have anything here
so I figured that if nothing and I just
played g5 and the one way that he can go
wrong here is still under with this and
then I I win by a miracle but of course
he didn't do that he can win my pawn and
yeah it was a draw and I wasn't very
happy with that but I couldn't really
find it improving for me funnily enough
it's a kind of quizzical right I mean
it's hard to be disappointed when you
don't really know where you went wrong
the john fighting for your second norm
tomorrow wednesday november 22nd is the
big day and you have the black pieces
against Amon Hamilton I've talked to a
lot of people and they're all saying you
know you can't really play for the norm
you just have to let it come if it comes
it's great but with the black pieces are
you gonna play for a win tomorrow I have
to play a bit more dynamically than I
normally would so yeah I think it's fair
to say that I'm gonna play for the norm
okay well good luck tomorrow let's take
a look at the standings right before the
final round
the Grandmaster section is quite
intriguing there are five players that
could win this event after the ninth
round and out of these five players two
of them can earn a grandmaster norm
that's John Michael Burke and Daniel
Gurevich several key games on Wednesday
for the ninth round Gurevich and Ashwin
a win in that
for either one will guarantee them first
place also playing around
John Burke vs. Amana Hamilton and
Stevens irk has to win his game against
Ravens start to even hope to win this
tournament and I'm here with Justin Wang
one of the norm hopefuls now the norm
winner in the International master
section Justin what a big day for you
congratulations on your win today thank
you you're welcome
against any Wang we were all looking at
the board we were all looking at you and
several others that could be winning a
norm today and are still in contention
tomorrow and with one day to spare you
got it
Justin if you can take us through the
game and show us what happened against
Danny and when you knew you had it right
I didn't really get why she played
Quincy six on I don't think it was very
useful all right h6 after h6 I was
planning to play here but
she probably did this because she was
worried about the g6 pawn so bf5 out I
was expecting
Bishop d5 or a booth later earlier
rookie three Bishop d5 ides expecting
done but now she didn't want to trade
bishops cleaners for Queen d7 looks for
it now I have basically have to trade
and then and now Bishop c2 is good
oh I played beautifully because I wanted
to do this fish it takes us in there
were Queen x h7 g e6 but it's case and
if I do dance I think Oh
two looks in the Bishop versus queen so
I decided to do this work I didn't like
Oh queen of voice so who g5 before took
Queen d5 okay ax B for ax B for losses
because it i I didn't calculates this
Queen b3 Ethan Bishop b1 all right I
only calculated Bishop c4 where I'm good
here
so
axb for it doesn't look good I think I
should have played maybe I think it's g5
k 5 take take their vision D 5
no actually probably a fourth year
no I didn't vision be one else just wins
right away when she played Rock XA - and
maybe I don't think I'm so someone twist
anymore and she plays cleanup day I come
here your route III rookie one queen of
three if she takes I can if she takes I
can do this then yeah I think it spoke
back to Olczyk so 25 Queen c5 I think he
I maybe she came by age five but it
still looks like it's okay it still
looks like draw
if 6 is evil
you know think just looks like a draw so
he's way she blended with III you see
was a bad move because after Queenie
five Queen d7 then I could now I can't
even cake and then I played rookie one
now she took and then I go to a winning
Queen in game and that that does it when
I saw you come out of the tournament
hall you asked me how many points to get
a norm did you know it was six did you
know you had clinched the IM norm when
you beat Annie I don't know because I
thought it was six but was someone
Carissa said it was like 6.5 so I was
like so many times it is six-and-a-half
it depends on the field in this instance
it was it was six in your case I was in
the tournament hall
whenever the round today began and I
noticed that your behavior at the board
perhaps stress management was different
from the others you make a move at the
very beginning and then go out into the
tournament hall and watch on a screen is
that less stressful for you than sitting
at the board and watching the game yeah
I think that's right I'd rather see the
move going to screen than issue very
interesting I would not have thought
that well Justin what are your thoughts
going into tomorrow
tomorrow I hope I could win tomorrow
what it's probably what it's probably
not going to be easy won't be easy going
for a win Justin thank you for joining
me here in the studio first
international master norm
Justin Wang let's take a look at the
standings in the i M norm section the
International master norm section is
much more clear-cut with only two
players capable of winning and two
players in the lead right now
Justin Wang with six points clinched his
I M norm today an international master
Torres roses also has six points these
two met in the first round and it was a
draw so it's up to their respective
games in the ninth round to determine
who will win this event and if they both
score equally then there will be a
playoff if there's one place you've got
to be on Wednesday November 22 at 11:00
a.m. I'll tell you right now watch these
games live on the Internet it's the
final round will there be another norm
earned and who will be the winners of
the GM and iam norm Fields check it out
on chest 24 and us chess champs calm